Joe Biden
he makes some pretty weird claims
and he's not the most reliable guy and
he's been one of the most notorious
Liars in American politics since at
least the 1980s
and we got another doozy the other doozy
is that Joe Biden who tells us that he's
a devout Catholic and he campaigns on
being a devout Catholic
actually grew up
in a black Protestant church
unless they want thing to rest I may be
a practicing Catholic we used to go to 7
30 Mass
every morning in high school and then on
College before I went to the black
church
not a joke Andy knows this not a joke I
went to the black church he made these
comments at Ebenezer Baptist Church in
Atlanta Georgia for Martin Luther King
day and Biden claims he says he went to
daily mass and then every day
he went to that to that black church
I assume he went with his friend corn
pop corn pop actually passed the
collection basket around uh Joe Biden he
wore big colorful hats you know come on
man listen here Jack that's the truth
listen you dog face pony soldier yeah I
grew up in a black church I was good
friends with Martin Luther King yeah you
know it no me and Frederick Douglass
yeah we used to go to the pool together
swim laps with Corn Pop he said I had
hairy legs come on Jack
come on man I don't think anybody
believes what what Biden is saying but
the most notable part of the story to me
is that
any way you slice it Joe Biden reveals
himself as dishonest
because if he if he lied about going to
the black church all the time as a kid
which is probably the case then he's a
liar but even that first part when he
says listen I'm a practicing Catholic
what what non-catholics might not know
is that
Catholics are not permitted to
participate in the religious ceremonies
of other religions and and other
denominations
so if you're a practicing Catholic and
you go and you were you're regularly
attending a Protestant
church and participating in those
activities that's actually considered a
sin in the Catholic Church you're
supposed to confess that sin when you go
to confession you wouldn't you would not
really be able to call yourself with a
straight face a practicing Catholic if
you are regularly and willfully
violating that that uh requirement of
the church
but but of course going to a Protestant
Church would be the very least of Joe
Biden's infractions against his faith
Joe Biden is giddy about abortion he he
not only supports abortion which is
utterly impermissible for a Catholic
politician but he supports funding
abortion Joe Biden supports radically
redefining marriage this is not a
permissible thing to do if you're a
Catholic politician it supports all
sorts of things that run contrary to the
faith so I mentioned this not not really
to say anything about
Catholicism but to say something about
Joe Biden
any way you cut this story he's either
he's a liar
he's not a practicing Catholic and he
probably didn't go to this church and
you can't believe a word that this guy
says and so when you get back to a
scandal like the classified document
Scandal this is why nobody believes his
excuses oh yeah Jack yeah I just we
forgot to take those documents yeah
that's too bad Jack that's why they
ended up there at the at the Penn Biden
Center well what about the documents in
your garage oh come on there fat don't
don't do me like that yeah it's next to
my Corvette it's cool it's all safe man
what about the other documents what
about this what about that he just
doesn't have any credibility at all this
is a man who's lied about his
professional career his beliefs his
accomplishments his involvement the
Civil Rights Movement that's another one
that keeps coming up he's like he's a
guy who lies about everything he'd lied
to you about what he had for breakfast
in the morning
and he he would even lie about a matter
as consequential as his faith now
speaking of politics and the Catholic
church I have seen something that you
have not seen yet but you are going to
want to see it because it's very very
cool this is an interview that Ben did
our very own Ben Shapiro did with Frank
Pavone Frank Pavone a very very
well-known Catholic priest the head of
priests for Life who was recently
shockingly laissized by the Vatican and
another word for that is defrocked they
say you're no longer allowed to be a
priest and it's a kind of a complex
thing because the the sacrament of holy
orders makes an indelible mark on
someone's Soul so there's a question can
you even
really ultimately lay aside somebody
don't well the churches said we're
taking away your faculties to be a
priest to to confer sacraments to
present yourself as a priest uh for what
for it's a little unclear it's not no
one has really seems to know exactly why
so he just went on Ben Shapiro's Sunday
special and he made a really really
important point about his pro-life
advocacy
how do you make the case to people that
that would say that you know Catholic
Doctrine or religious Doctrine it allows
for a variety of opinions in terms of
how you vote so okay sure the Republican
party is for life sure the Republican
Party opposes same-sex marriage but the
Democratic party is more for social
justice matters it's more for economic
redistribution how do you privilege one
idea over another idea and how does that
mesh with Catholic Doctrine how can you
draw such a clear dividing line between
how people should vote shouldn't you
just sort of speak to Broad principles
and then whatever people do in the
privacy of the voting booth is what they
should is what they choose to do right
and you know based on the dictates of
conscience
the relationship between the issues
needs to be looked at nobody in the
pro-life Community says abortion is the
only issue what we say is that the right
to live is the foundation of every issue
if an issue is an issue in the first
place it's because it somehow impacts
human life why are we concerned about
poverty well people have a right to food
clothing and shelter why because they
have a right to live why am I concerned
about unemployment well people have a
right to make a living why because they
have a right to live protection from
terrorism you can go down the list and
it's like okay the value of life is
obviously at the core of every issue
such an important point
that conservatives don't make nearly as
much as we should
life is not merely one issue among many
life is the foundational right if we are
to have any rights at all we have to
have the right from Life on which all of
the other rights rely
Declaration of Independence says we have
rights to life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness life is obviously the most
important if any of those are rights
life has to be the most important
because you can't have Liberty without
life you can't pursue happiness if you
don't have life
and so when when someone like Joe Biden
comes out and he says well listen I you
know I'm practicing Catholic but I don't
I don't believe in the right to life
well you're saying okay I don't I don't
believe in any rights at all then
I I don't believe in the most basic
right of of all of them and so there's
been some speculation again we don't
know why Pavone was layoutized I want to
call him father pavon I guess I'm not
supposed to call him father Pavone
anymore feels kind of weird to call him
Mr Pavone but but in any case he was he
was layicized some speculate because of
his pro-life advocacy and because he was
perhaps disobedient to his Bishops
and other people who may or may not have
told him to calm down with all the
pro-life stuff again I don't know there
this has not been a transparent matter
but
what Pavone is saying is
I can't pipe down about this
this is a fundamental issue there was
there was one report that Pavone had
refused to to give Absolution to
unrepentant Democrats
and this was a big headline sounds
really shocking the sacrament of
confession is where Catholics go and
they confess their sins and the priest
deriving from Christ's conferring of the
right to loose and to bind Christ says
here is the power to forgive sins what
what sins you forgive are forgiven and
what sins you retain are retained and so
what pavon is saying is I'm I'm not
going to I cannot absolve someone of
their sins if they're not repentant and
the report was again I haven't heard him
say this but the report was that in some
cases he wouldn't give Absolution to
people who say vote for a Democrat vote
for some radically pro-abortion
politician and don't repent of that
well fair enough it seems to me if if
you're if you're sorry if you say look I
supported abortion in the past and that
was wrong and I'm sorry please I'm
asking God's forgiveness then you
receive God's forgiveness but if you
don't if you if you say yeah I support
baby killing politicians and and yeah I
think it's totally great to support
legal abortion and and even
taxpayer-funded abortion okay give me
absolution
pavon's saying I can't do that because
you're not you're not repentant a lot of
the opposition to Pavone is he's too
political he's getting too involved in
politics okay
I I don't even really know what that
means
yes we don't want to see priests you
know just chumming it up with one
candidate or some other candidate or
something we we want our priests to be
doing something different than our
politicians are doing sure okay I see
all of that but we're supposed to
pretend now that our our spiritual
leaders have to remain neutral there's
no neutrality we're in a spiritual war
and what we're supposed to pretend that
the guy who's running to save the babies
and the guy was running to kill the
babies that we're going to not have a
preference between those two things
we're not going to tell our flock who to
go to I'm not a priest I don't have a
flock but we're not priests are not
supposed to do that give me a break
that's completely insane it's a
historical it's completely incoherent
and I really hope it all works out with
with uh
Pavone with Frank Pavone I hope it would
be it's a real shame to see what's
happened and it would be good to see him
brought back into the priesthood at some
future day I hope especially if they
only booted him out for uh for being too
pro-life it would be nice if they could
kind of work it out you know and have
him get back to his uh overall excellent
work
[Music]
thank you